we actually align modernity with
pluralism I think that's the big
category mistake on Peter Berger who's
the great sort of sociologists at
religion you know who one time was a big
supporter of the secularization thesis
arguably the most sort of the biggest
proponent of it when he switched and
suddenly said lo actually pluralism is
the modern thing I think that's it and
that's what's the core of why we think
an American model loosely termed is
sweeping the world people are choosing
which religion to have they're doing the
same thing as Thomas Jefferson did you
know they're looking at the Bible and
cutting out the bits they feel like it's
like I want this and I'm on this and I'm
going to change this it's a much more
individual thing and the reason why that
is relevant to politics and public life
is if people are choosing their religion
rather than just inheriting it then that
means that when they go into the voting
booth they go into work even they're not
going to leave it at home in the same
way as they might have done before
it's the forces of progress are driving
it you look at globalization you look at
technology you look at the lot of
democracy you know if you you're giving
these when you give people the vote
strangely a lot of religious people go
and vote for religious parties when you
give people technology strangely some
people who actually use it best are
often people like the mega churches
they're very very quick on to this if
you look at the way that that the
globalization spreads I think
globalization actually encourages the
demand for religion in two ways there's
one group of people who think we want
religion to be a sort of storm shelter
and you can see that quite a lot that
particular in the Islamic world but you
can focus it even rural arkansas rural
india you can see these people who think
that the world's out there it's a
frightening difficult place and religion
is a form of protection against it by
contrast what we also identified which i
think is the sort of unappreciative
bitch is that for lots of people lots of
up-and-coming people visit the mega
churches America you don't see poor
downtrodden people there you see smart
young suburb nights they see this as a
way to get ahead to get ahead of other
people very very true in China very very
true and career very true in Latin
America we see Pentecostalism spreading
very quickly and the one exception is
Europe which we can to come back to
which the harder case to make this
argument then all other areas of the
world for better or worse in it that
those things are being lied and actually
is going with a if that's the sort of
demand side that there's a so deeper
demand side is actually whether we like
it or not man seems to be a theatre opik
beast you know given the option to
believe in God or some kind of afterlife
or some kind of meaning they will do so
and if you want the quintessential
example of the sort of modern religion
it's your president you know look at
Barack Obama there is a man whose life
was that he wasn't sure about it he
found the meaning in a Chicago church
and what's interesting about Obama I
think is that he is somebody who wants
you taken one to the international stage
which is obviously already on but once
you once you put that particular element
of faith on the international stage I
think you're going to see a very
different reaction to American religion
then you had with george w bush george w
bush typify
all the things that Europeans in
particular found suspicious and wrong
about American religion nation very hard
very intolerant it wasn't it wasn't the
same thing but I think a lot of
Europeans could identify with this
clever young well-educated man looking
for something more to life and
discovering in the church I think any
accidents are all the best-selling
religious book is called the purpose
driven life but that's what that's the
bit which is striking a chord with
globalization so that's all the demand
side that's why people are going for it
and you're just one last thing on it
there is now quite a lot of science
again for better or worse which shows
that religious people are wealthier
healthier and happier with non-religious
people so to that extent eat quote
unquote works and you know Dawkins is
very interesting on that the other thing
which is driving religion if that's the
demand side is supply and you have the
spread of american-style competitive
religion where you are you know you make
great efforts to make religion much
easier you make church is more
comfortable you use every form of modern
technology you embed it into people's
lives and you see that spreading into
other religions like Hinduism Buddhism
Islam as well and you say it spreading
around the world
that's a very good
and that that is the area where gold is
back is the hardest argument to prove
that said I think on one side it's clear
that the extent there are two parts of
this but one is saying here is the
politics they're going to be involving
religion and then there's also the basic
facts of people perhaps becoming more
religious generally the on the first bit
that works completely with Europe I
think political Europe is suddenly got
religion back into the public square in
a way that people I thought just assume
they banished it that's partly because
of the arrival of Islam in a big way
suddenly you know it's a big big part of
domestic politics in a variety of
European countries Sharia headscarves
where exactly reliable T mosque and
state should be what children should be
taught whether were religious schools
are a good idea or a bad idea these are
all issues which are suddenly floating
back to the center you also see it I
think a degree amongst the leaders you
have Blair who famously said we don't do
God or other his specs when did you know
Blair is now running a faith and
politics Institute you have golden brown
again sort of quite a delicious burger
Sarkozy wrote a book about it see the
influence of all the the East European
countries so within the political world
I I have no doubt that the same kind of
culture wars and stuff which have been
part of the American world are going to
be part of the European world in a
different way but but certainly in a way
that Europeans just never imagined
possible whenever they've looked at
American politics they've always it's
always been a bit where they thought
that's an abomination it's not going to
come here what will it is said politics
yes you know God is very much back in
European politics the difficult bit is
God is back in terms of personal
religiosity there I think the evidence
is it is much more mixed on the one hand
Church attenders generally in most
places or the mainline churches are
still going down against AI I think you
could argue that on the on the edge it
is things are beginning to happen you
can see pentecostalism Greg very fast
and France you can see if you go to the
east end of london is you've multitude
of different religions competing 2
million britons have been through
something called the Alpha course which
is a sort of I'm kind of simplified
massively
bit like the version of The Purpose
Driven Life in others desert that
there's a degree of change there which
just shows things are going adult
confirmations as it other change
childhood confirmations getting down
adult ones I people older suddenly
deciding I want to commit myself to the
Anglican Church whatever those are
actually going up I my guess is over
time the same sort of forces which have
been at work in America as the European
religious market get sort of freer and
easier and more competitive they will
work ie that if you are a suburbanite in
Bordeaux or Birmingham England you will
have some of the same kind of reasons to
drift towards religion the same sub
search for meaning the same some case
the same free of sports storm shelter
all those things will combine in the
same way as they do in Birmingham
Alabama or wherever that that's it says
there's too much similarity there for it
not to swing back a bit but no we're not
predicting that you know we're going to
reach a stage or it certainly at any
time soon where seventy-six percent of
Europeans immediately identified
themselves as christian